Raus auf die Straße darf er noch nicht:
Olli,
der erste autonom fahrende Bus in Berlin.
Hindernisse erkennt er mit
Hilfe von Sensoren.
Auf einem Testgelände dreht
er seit drei Monaten seine Runden.
Ein Bus ohne Fahrer – so stellt sich
der Verkehrsforscher Weert Canzler
die Fahrzeuge der Zukunft vor.
Das ist tatsächlich Real Life
und da lernt er natürlich auch.
Und das ist dann damit verbunden, dass
man manchmal auch dann Ausfälle hat
oder dass er plötzlich bremst.
Ein bisschen lernen muss
er schon noch, oder?
Der muss schon noch lernen,
das ist ganz am Anfang.
Ich meine, so lange gibt es diese
Technik nicht und die ist hochkomplex.
Schon in wenigen Jahren
sollen die selbstfahrenden Busse
in der Stadt unterwegs sein.
Und das ist erst der Anfang.
Denn so könnte es auf den
Straßen von morgen aussehen:
Autonome Mobile aller Art bringen
uns selbstständig ans Ziel
und wir haben die Wahl zwischen
vielen verschiedenen Verkehrsmitteln.
Das Zauberwort heißt Verknüpfung,
also im Fachdeutsch – im Fachbegriff
– Intermodalität, also die Verknüpfung
verschiedener Verkehrsmittel.
Und das private Auto kann‘s nicht sein.
Das ist einfach völlig ineffizient.
Das private Auto wird in der Innenstadt
mittel- und langfristig vermutlich
ganz verschwinden.
Die Straßen sind schon jetzt voll.
In Berlin gibt es mehr als 1,2 Millionen
private PKW und Firmenautos
– und jedes Jahr kommen
ein paar tausend dazu.
Lärm, Stau, schlechte Luft – das ruft
Visionäre mit Alternativen auf den Plan.
Idee Nummer Eins:
Das Start-Up Clever Shuttle
bietet zum Beispiel ein modernes
Sammeltaxi mit Elektroantrieb.
Per App kann man sich
einen Wagen bestellen.
Auf einer individuell festgelegten Route
werden dann weitere
Fahrgäste mitgenommen
– im Grunde wie bei einem klassischen
Taxi auch, nur effizienter und günstiger.
Die Idee dahinter ist, dass man
Wege in einer Stadt bündelt.
Wenn zwei Leute auf ähnlichen
Wegen buchen, macht es Sinn,
sie gemeinsam zu befördern,
weil es eben verkehrsreduzierend wirkt.
Anstatt zweimal ein Auto zu
nehmen, nimmt man eben nur eins.
Und jeder einzelne Fahrgast
spart eine Menge Geld.
Also wir unterbieten Taxipreise
momentan um 50 Prozent.
Und in Zukunft könnten die Sammeltaxis
sogar Teil des öffentlichen
Nahverkehrs werden.
Sie fahren dann auf Schienen,
doch Fahrpläne und feste
Haltestellen gibt es nicht.
Sie werden per Smartphone
bestellt und finden den Weg von alleine.
Die Zahl der privaten Fahrzeuge
könnte in Städten also sinken
– dafür gibt es immer
mehr Carsharing-Autos.
In Berlin, so schätzen Experten,
werden die sich in den nächsten 20
Jahren mindestens verfünffacht haben.
Werden wir also auf unser
eigenes Auto verzichten müssen?
In einem autobegeisterten
Land wie Deutschland
wird die Mehrheit der Bürger
erst einmal dagegen sein.
Das weiß auch diese Berliner
Kiez-Initiative,
die Autos am liebsten abschaffen will.
Bis es so weit ist, kann man mit ihrer App
Getaway vorhandene PKW besser nutzen.
Wer sein Auto nicht braucht,
der kann es in dieser Zeit dem
Nachbarn zur Verfügung stellen.
Ich lasse mir eine Technik einbauen,
ganz einfach so in der Größe eines
klassischen CD-ROM-Laufwerks.
Und das sorgt dann dafür, dass über die
App von Getaway das Auto zu bedienen ist
– beziehungsweise nicht zu bedienen
– zu öffnen ist, wieder zu schließen ist,
und die ganze Abrechnung
findet über die App statt.
Und noch eine Idee haben sie umgesetzt:
Statt ein eigenes Auto zu fahren, kann
man auch ein Lastenfahrrad mieten
– natürlich mit Elektroantrieb.